back in the day dude if there was like
no movies like in the 1 1800s you and I
were at a cafe you know had Cafe in
1700s but they didn't have
movies yeah yeah yeah so you and I yeah
they had coffee shops right they had
coffee shops in coffee shops like turkey
didn't have like Turkish when did
Turkish coffee happen I don't know man
you're going to have me on this podcast
you got to check your history first no
okay hold you and I are on the uh in a
cabin that makes making coffee I can see
that okay you're in the cabin in the
frontier you're live half a mile down I
live in a cabin and all we have is a
chess board right that's what you
weren't too far off uh Turkish coffee1
15555 thank you no but coffee shops no
coffee shops but they had Turkish coffee
dude so what I'm saying let me make this
argument all right okay okay so they
made coffee right yeah only at home I'm
sure there was a place that some guy
goes hey I make it the best come to mine
that's true okay so all right and we
meet at that guy's [__] thing man
why' you you [__] question me about
the fu I helped you by saying 1555 what
the [__] is going on around here man Hae
come on that's Let It Go oh you did it
that's a few years quite after the Magna
Carta
155 yeah that's true that's true anyway
I think that you and I would play
because it's like it's their
XBox you know it's no what year is this
1700 yeah yeah what else you going to do
you play chess Checkers what else some
weird sport I probably do more cooler
[__] than hang around with you and play
chess all day like [__] [__] I'll
probably ride a horse and steal I'll be
like a bandit Mexicans were Bandidos
back then I think when did Bandido look
that up Bandido when did Bandido was
created
Created that's so [__] been around oh
wait that's a club never mind 1800s oh I
probably would have been the first
Bandido there you go all right I'm a
Bandido too right we we do this so we
Rob the banks and then we play chess on
our free time yeah like by the campfire
yeah I can see that yeah I'll be
like that's how talk I'll be like
see
some yeah you're worthy opponent yeah
yeah you said
Asian you ASI what you g KH what the
[__] who the opponent who the opponent
why can't I do a Mexican accent what the
[__] and is this you're oh you're
twiddling your it's not like a very
traditional thick Mexican mustache but I
can twiddle the best I can um but you
still have interest of acting yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think you're going to
get there you'll get [__] yeah yeah
excited for you dude oh thank you are
you excited about your life yeah I guess
so no come on bro I'm just like real
dude I just feel like shit's always up
in the air and it's it's like I'm
excited but I'm also
like
like nobody touched me like you get like
that you know I don't know what the [__]
you mean like flying I think that you
can relate to that like the feeling of
like everything's up in the air like you
don't really know what dude is around
the corner I was talking to my therapist
yesterday M and I was I go yeah these
are things are happening and I go but I
don't know I just feel like I don't know
what the hell is going on and she stops
me she goes cuz she has she's a
therapist for a lot of like big names
and she goes
everyone feels that way that's nice from
top to bottom I thought she was going to
be like Bobby out of all the [__]
Comedians and actors I represent or like
I talk to like you're [__] killing it
some of these guys suck like no no she
goes that's the nature of what we do
you're always going to feel like that
but I want to tell you something okay
there's a
um there's a level in which you get into
the
club and and once you're in the club
it's almost impossible to get out unless
you get canell mhm so I want to let you
know welcome to the
club bro I've been waiting to hear that
you're in now and it's hard to get in
but you're you're in and so it's like
you're just now you're just going to
wait in line with the rest of us okay so
we wait in line we read for something or
we we get considered for something or
you know what I mean play chess in the
meantime yeah we play chess in the
meantime but right now you're in the
group congratulations give him a round
of applause you did it man you did it
but unfortunately haime you're not he'll
get there he's going stand up too you
just stand up now oh bro oh so cute you
know what he looks like a young Robert
Kelly a young like you a little
bit like a Mexican me well because of
the Beanie and stuff yeah yeah there on
camera here I'm definitely like H do you
want to get on camera just come look
stand over here by the camera right here
and look and look there get over here or
sit George's camera cuzz he has a mic
stop stop